Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
FRANCESCO Mizzau
Open Source, la rivoluzione invisibile.
Sono molto contento di questo invito,
perché quando tengo
corsi e lezioni
parlare di Open Source
è la cosa che mi piace di più
e premetto che
nella mia vita,
nella mia carriera, io ho prodotto
software per circa 20 anni:
dal 1988 ho cominciato un'attività
di produttore di software
e in questo senso
ho commissionato programmi,
progettato, disegnato, debuggato.
Per cui per me
questa cosa dell'Open Source,
quando piano piano è apparsa,
si è manifestata,
alla fine è stata
proprio come un amore,
un qualcosa che da essere celato,
nascosto, tenuto segreto,
in qualche modo si è piano piano aperto.
Allora, in questa piccola dissertazione
vorrei farvi notare
come mai secondo me questo
fenomeno costituisce una rivoluzione
e come mai è "invisibile",
nel senso che sta accadendo
come le radici di una pianta
che sta sottoterra,
e non ce ne si accorge.
È praticamente una cosa
che sta accadendo da
- da quando sta accadendo
ora lo vedremo.
Ci sono due aspetti che mi interessa
mettere in evidenza.
Primo: quanto il software
sia una cosa così strategica,
così importante per la nostra
civiltà contemporanea,
e quanto sia alla fine carica di potere,
di vari tipi di poteri, che
sono nascosti nel software.
E la cosa interessante è appunto
che questa pratica dell'Open Source
ha alla fine aperto
la possibilità di leggere, di scoprire,
di sapere di cosa si tratta.
Quando diciamo Open Source,
per chi non lo sa,
Open Source è il codice sorgente.
Qualsiasi programma che fa funzionare
un computer, una macchina fotografica,
- e a questo punto anche
un televisore, una lavatrice -
è un testo che, in forma sorgente,
è un linguaggio che dà le istruzioni,
e in forma compilata
è stato agglomerato
e compattato
in istruzioni per la macchina,
quindi istruzioni come:
apri, chiudi, accendi, spegni,
conta il tempo,
misura la temperatura,
se la temperatura è così
spegni la lavatrice
- e in questo senso
tutto questo è, diciamo,
un po' la storia dell'informatica.
Passiamo alla seconda.
In questo senso le proprietà
del software sono particolari.
La prima che mi piace dire è
che in qualche modo è invisibile.
Primo perché generalmente
noi usiamo un computer
senza pensare a cosa succede dentro,
a meno che non facciamo questo mestiere;
oppure accendiamo
il motore della macchina
ma non pensiamo
che c'è tutto un meccanismo
che si mette in moto, di controllo.
Qualcuno, qualche programmatore,
qualche progettista
ha pianificato questo processo,
l'ha scritto,
è diventato un ciclo
ed è poi diventato una tecnologia
e un sistema, uno strumento.
Per sua natura poi, il software,
essendo un costrutto umano
che è stato elaborato
e che è quindi frutto di lavoro,
di pensiero e di prove,
insomma di fatica,
in qualche modo è intelligenza
che viene composta in piccole sequenze,
che messe insieme producono
sequenze più ampie,
e in qualche modo è intelligenza.
Allora questo software per sua natura
una volta che è scritto è modificabile
nel senso che si può riciclare,
si può riusare.
Questa riusabilità è potenziabile,
[mentre] nel mondo
delle grandi imprese
nel mondo, diciamo,
dove il codice resta chiuso,
è appannaggio solo di chi lo possiede.
Allora, come è successo?
Ecco io ho la sensazione che
in qualche modo il software
rappresenti più di ogni altra cosa
proprio il nostro sapere
scientifico quotidiano.
Ormai, qualunque cosa
andiamo a fare
viene poi portata e lavorata
- anche le tecnologie della
comunicazione- attraverso un software.
Come è potuto accadere, allora,
che una cosa così potente,
così alla chiave, diciamo,
di tutti i tipi di controllo
finanziario, economico, militare,
sia diventata aperta?
Questa è la domanda che mi ponevo,
esaminando la portata
rivoluzionaria di tutto ciò.
Allora questo è accaduto
- perché forse la storia contemporanea
non viene ben raccontata -
perché di fatto delle persone,
che poi sono stati chiamati hacker,
in qualche modo hanno messo,
hanno dato un'anima
al software e alla tecnologia
e hanno seminato,
fatto i primi atti, gesti costruttivi
che sono diventati,
poi, lo sviluppo
di questi 30 anni di tecnologia.
Ne vediamo alcuni.
L'Homebrew Computer Club
era un collettivo di persone
che si incontravano per costruirsi
in casa il proprio computer
usando i pochi, o comunque
la scarsità di pezzi di computer
che c'erano all'epoca.
In questo club, che si è riunito
per più di dieci anni in California,
sono passati tutti i più pazzi
appassionati di tecnologia
ex hippy, in questo clima
degli anni '70.
Ecco da questo, da questo club
sono passati Steve Jobs e Wozniak
che poi hanno fondato la Apple.
Il primo personal computer -
sono stati loro a pensare
che i computer dovessero essere
per tutta la società,
non è stato pianificato dalle aziende.
Le aziende pensavano che il computer
fosse una cosa da grandi imprese.
L'hanno avuta loro, questa visione.
Così Stallman, che poi ha fondato
la Free Software Foundation,
è stato quello che ha visto
un'altra cosa, ha detto:
ma certo, se non so
cosa c'è dentro il software,
il software mi ingabbia,
mi può far diventare prigioniero.
Il software deve essere libero.
Se il computer è mio,
il software che sta girando
dentro questo computer
non deve poter fare
qualcosa che io non voglio.
Per esempio, anche Tim Berners-Lee,
che è l'inventore del World Wide Web,
ha cominciato a pensare
a questo meccanismo
che poi è diventato una rivoluzione,
e si è posto il problema, fin dall'inizio,
di evitare che diventasse
un oggetto troppo commerciale
e quindi che rimanesse libero,
e ci è riuscito.
Gli altri personaggi,
sono Linus Torvalds,
che è quello che ha scritto
il kernel di Linux,
cioè ha creato, in maniera anche folle,
un programma che doveva
diventare, anzi
che è diventato un sistema operativo.
Questo sistema operativo,
dalla piccola cosa di uno
studente di 21 anni che era,
connesso con una realtà
che ancora, che già esisteva,
di queste persone che già
avevano questa visione,
è diventato il sistema operativo
più diffuso al mondo.
È il sistema operativo
che governa qualsiasi apparecchio
che utilizziamo tutti i giorni,
ed è il sistema operativo,
insieme alla suite LAMP,
cioè altri strumenti, anche loro,
gratuiti, open e aperti
che sono alla base
della tecnologia Internet oggi.
Scusate, ma qui ho troppa roba.
Allora come - puoi andare avanti.
I punti di forza e di debolezza
dell'Open Source.
Diffusione e collaborazione.
Internet ha creato poi
il meccanismo
di leggere reciprocamente
il codice sorgente.
È diventato una prassi di tutti quanti,
quindi tutti quanti
possiamo utilizzare l'esperienza,
la conoscenza di qualcun altro.
Questo accade particolarmente
nel mondo del software.
Ma se noi prendiamo questa visione
e la portiamo fuori dal software
ci rendiamo conto
che può essere
applicata in tanti altri ambiti,
e si sta applicando in altri ambiti
come l'architettura,
come le scienze sociali
la conoscenza- e infatti molti oggi
hanno cominciato
a pubblicare le proprie, i propri libri
i propri libri, le proprie pubblicazioni
in una forma aperta,
in modo che più persone
potessero leggere
il loro contenuto, le loro idee.
Cosa è successo, poi?
Che ora, questa rivoluzione
ha dei nemici.
A qualcuno- c'è tutta una parte
della società che si oppone,
però questa cosa accade lo stesso.
Perché?
Perchè chi usa le tecnologie Open Source
in qualche modo ha più possibilità
di avere relazioni, di conoscere,
e quindi ha un continuo stimolo
di autoapprendimento
che invece chi adotta
la tecnologia "chiusa" non può avere.
La critica
che viene fatta sempre
all'Open Source è:
ma com'è che si fa a guadagnare?
Se io prendo
il mio programma, il mio libro,
e lo metto gratuito disponibile,
- questa è la critica
che vien sempre rivolta -
come pagheremo la creatività,
se non ci sono diritti d'autore,
se il contenuto è gratuito?
La mia, e non solo mia, risposta è che
in qualche modo l'Open Source
è come un ecosistema
dove si è complementari:
io, per esempio,
ho trovato due casi.
Un esempio è quello tipico
dello sviluppatore di software:
lui legge, trova delle cose,
dei lavori fatti da altri,
impara una nuova competenza,
questa nuova competenza
la usa per fare un lavoro
per qualcuno e quindi viene pagato.
A sua volta, quello che può fare
in più lo mette come dono,
lo condivide nello stesso
progetto software
o in alcuni casi
fa anche una donazione;
però in molti casi uno aggiunge solo
un pezzo di traduzione,
un qualcosa che aggiunge al progetto,
oppure fa un nuovo progetto.
L'altro esempio è il modello
del copyright-copyleft.
Se tu fai un libro, e questo
libro è sotto copyright,
viene stampato, ne vengono
vendute 1000 copie,
100 persone lo leggono.
Se tu invece scrivi un libro,
lo metti in un formato copyleft,
senza diritti, gratuitamente,
lo scaricano in 100.000,
lo leggono in 10.000.
Le tue idee si diffondono molto di più,
e tu acquisisci una reputazione per cui
la tua conoscenza vale
e ti viene richiesta come lavoro.
Riguardo alle conclusioni,
io penso che ci siano stati
tutta una serie
di movimenti giuridici,
cioè soprattutto leggi e tentativi
che servono in qualche modo
a bloccare questa trasformazione.
Vi faccio due esempi semplicissimi.
Le nuove norme sul copyright
introdotte negli ultimi anni
erano un tentativo
di questo modello precedente
di difendere la proprietà intellettuale,
che poi è quella delle grandi imprese,
non è la proprietà intellettuale
dei singoli.
Questo nuovo modello viene
ancora percepito da alcuni
come un qualcosa
che proprio non esiste,
che non ha forza.
Invece è successo l'opposto.
È successo che questo modello
sta vincendo.
Il caso dei server
Internet è uno,
ma il caso di Skype e della
telefonia è un secondo.
Dall'idea della condivisione sono nate
migliaia di progetti e iniziative.
Anche il TED stesso è figlio
del concetto dell'Open Source.
La cultura in qualche modo
è stata una forte spinta di innovazione,
e continuerà a esserlo,
e secondo me
sarà questa la rivoluzione.
Per concludere, ecco
l'esempio del peer to peer.
La tecnologia del peer to peer,
che sembrava un giochetto,
è riuscita a trasformare
l'industria della musica
in un modo imprevedibile,
e oggi le multinazionali della musica
hanno dovuto reinventarsi
e l'attivitàdei musicisti è cambiata.
Alcuni continuano a dire: ah, ma io
come faccio, non ho i diritti.
Di fatto fanno più concerti,
e la musica viene data gratis,
cioè è solo un cambio di modello.
Chiaramente, non a tutti sta bene.
In questo senso Attali,
con questo concludo,
nella sua "Breve storia del futuro"
immagina che dopo questo confitto
tra visioni del mondo diverse
- lui li chiama i transumani -
ma si possono immaginare anche
come questi hacker culturali,
saranno le persone
che in qualche modo decidono
di prendere questo approccio
in senso globale,
quindi di dedicarsi agli altri
e non solo a guadagnare denaro
e posizioni.
Questa cosa sembra impalpabile
ed è difficile anche descriverla,
però è una cosa
che ci sta accadendo davanti.
Il software governa sempre
di più i processi umani,
e sempre di più il fatto
di scambiarci
la conoscenza e la diffusione
sta trasformando il mondo.
(Applausi)